We know that what we do is stimulating the area underneath the target which sits about here.
We know that that area is tightly connected to a region deep inside called
the anterior cingulate cortex, which is
crucially involved in depression.
And so we are relaying that activation to
different parts of the brain that
appeared to be under active in
depression and basically turning them on.
Here's what happens the first day. You walk in and you're nervous, I was nervous because
this was something new. I was seated in a
spa chair and I had a coil placed
against my head, and the doctor with the
assistant figures out your motor
threshold. So they did this by these test
pulses and when my finger, my thumb
twitched appropriately they knew they
had the right spot on my head.
Then they moved it forward and they figured out the dosage. So that was the first day.
I was astounded at how easy it was. I was
absolutely relieved that
I was, that it didn't hurt, other than the fact that the tapping, when the tapping goes in
it's four seconds on, very fast da da da da da da.
That's intense and it did take some getting used to. But what was really wonderful
about my first day with TMS was that my
TMS coordinator and the doctor both
managed my expectations. They both said look this isn't a quick fix this takes time.
It's a cumulative process. It starts
at the outermost part of your brain and
it has to keep overtime, every day going
for this treatment, work its way deeper
into the brain so that you can feel the
benefit of TMS.
The fact that they said you know don't don't expect an instant relief here. You're going to
you're going to need to be patient but
you're going to need to be confident and
commit that this will this will help you
So that was my first day.
Most of the time people do need daily treatments for a substantial time.
It may be as short as a week it may be as long as five or six weeks to get the full benefit of treatment.
Following that the hope is that having gotten people out of the deep hole of depression
it easier to stay out of the hole with an occasional boost of a transcranial magnetic stimulation treatment,
once a week, once every several weeks to keep you going well.